c'est peut-être aller les détails dans
la poche comment ça il y en a pas vous
avez fait quoi je trouve à voir combien
pensez à prendre ensemble c'est parce
que c'était parce que tu ne racontes
afin de rappeler j du sexe fort - il
monte entre eux et qui
l'enfance ses 100 ans c'est l'âge où
vous en sortez j'espère c'est l'âge où
on n'est pas encore assez mûr mais pas
encore assez forts tenez voilà on peut
et par les nazis qu'ils ont cherché la
dernière fois a été chaude le camp mais
après moi je m'en fous tu m'accuses
cabine
mais le truc c'est que tu es venu chez
moi plusieurs fois dormir à poil dans
mon lit tu vois là c'est un peu plus dur
tu veux te dire je suis pas lesbienne
faut que le distinguer du temps que
comme quoi vont bien
mais ravi un bon encontre et main c'est
très gentil de l'aider à préparer ce
genre de philosophie
mais si tu raisonnes quelles conditions
j'avais honte d'être avec nous si
j'avais peur qu'on est content tu prends
pour une conne je te prends pas pour une
qualité jamais parce qu'on dégage son
équipe
pourquoi tu pleures jme repas